i'm gonna get in a question about china
and the censorship that y'all talked
about michael you're in l.a
correct your mayor admitted at the
beginning of the month that
yes we actually were kind of you know it
is the protest it was all this that that
went to this
um i also have to take issue with you of
sending so many progressive voters to my
state
i know we want to get him out as soon as
possible
although i i have to say we we are
fighting a
probably a losing battle here because
the left really has taken over certainly
la
and california what what mayor garcetti
has
shown here is a total weakness but
but kind of this credibility problem
we're all talking about initially when
the riots broke out he said i'm not
going to call in the national guard and
then what happens they run roughshod
over the city
he has to do that and it shows i think
the political symbolism
and politicize this epidemic has become
mayor garcetti gave a speech
in an empty dodger stadium completely
empty we're looking at 50 000 seats
nobody's in it and he put the mask on
obviously no one was
was at risk of being infected there and
i i just think
that's so pretentious that's what makes
people like you
and senator cruz and me and everybody
out there across the country who's
listening and watching that just makes
us okay
that's a little much like you're you're
outside i mean we were told that the sun
and fresh air kills this thing does it
or does it not i mean i don't know
we may all have been told that we have
to quarantine so they can change the
batteries and the birds i don't know
we're all asking genuine questions at
this point because nobody trusts anybody
um i want to switch from this really
quickly and i i i we
you guys did you guys talked about
censorship because we are in this cancel
culture battle
um i i would love thoughts on this
because i
maintained that it's not going to be
like anybody like me
or either of you or anyone in dc or on
cable news that actually ends this
i think it's going to be those unlikely
allies like the jk rowlings and the
barney weisses and
people that on the big issues we really
do fall on that same square
what um whichever one of you wants to
tackle what are your what are your
thoughts on this
well let me say that real briefly on the
last the mat the mask issue
if we can somehow convince whether it's
garcetti or nancy pelosi or chuck
schumer
to wear a gag instead of a mask i think
you will see
massive support for a mandatory gag
policy on on some of the idiocy they're
saying
um look shifting to to
cancel culture and and the left and the
media
um and actually that joke the fact that
it's a joke
so i'm saying that but i'm not in fact
arguing that you physically gagged nancy
pelosi
and to be honest yes you just did
because
the idiocy she's saying if people
actually listen
to they'll realize it's wrong